are diplomatic editor James Bays is at
the United Nations Headquarters and
James of course it's not just the war in
Ukraine it's also a time of natural
disasters around the world millions of
people desperately in in need of help
that is something that's on the UN
Agenda as well isn't it
absolutely when world leaders come here
every year for this week they discuss
all the crises in the world but this
year very much the war in Ukraine is
dominating uh proceedings uh we're
supposed to have a meeting later on
today with the Chinese foreign minister
and state councilor Wang Yi with the U.S
Secretary of State Anthony blinken we
had the news overnight that the
Secretary of State's father sadly has
passed away so not clear whether that
meeting will go ahead and if it does who
will participate from the U.S but that
is likely to a meeting that's dominated
by events in Ukraine I would have
thought as well as lots of other issues
that those two superpowers need to
discuss let's discuss uh what's been
going on this week with an important
player that's the president of the
international Committee of the Red Cross
Peter Maurer uh thank you for joining us
here on Al Jazeera let me start with
Ukraine the situation on the ground the
humanitarian situation you're one of the
biggest humanitarian organizations in
the world how about as it well it's uh
pretty Stark as you know we have been in
Ukraine on the ground since 2014 and we
have seen eight years of protracted
conflict which has already weakened the
society and disrupted the Ukrainian
Society since February with the
intensification of warfare with the
level of Destruction internal
displacement
refugees coming out of Ukraine this
country has been heavily affected and
therefore our response to all the
multiplicity of humanitarian needs had
to be scaled importantly today Ukraine
is the largest operation of icrc and
this is a reflection of the humanitarian
needs on the ground
not just a humanitarian organization you
have in the International System a
unique role of of
governing the Geneva conventions which
are effectively are the rules of War
historic role you have there can I ask
you with that hat on the situation in
Ukraine only in the last few hours the
UN Commission of inquiries which is
looking into Ukraine has talked about
war crimes how worried are you that the
rules of war in Ukraine and elsewhere
are no longer being respected we are of
course worried in Ukraine and globally
as you rightly say we are involved with
the parties to the conflict with the
Armed Forces with the security forces to
have international humanitarian law
respected and there is no conflict in
the world where we don't see disrespect
the question is how we work afterwards
with the party how we try to influence
them and as you know it is really the
template of confidential dialogue the
methodology to really go to the
Commanders uh to the Ministers of
Defense with our findings on the ground
and to ask for better behavior for
change of behavior for accountability
within the armed forces and here I think
in Ukraine and elsewhere it's a huge uh
it's a huge challenge between the
necessity to protect civilian
populations and the military objectives
to defeat the adversary we always see
the balance tilt towards military logic
instead of protection logic of civilians
and this is what challenges us each and
every day but in Ukraine and elsewhere
we really try to forge our ways into the
mindset and into the thinking and into
the military orders in order to allow
International humanitarian law to at
least have some relevance in the
conflict and then I should say you
course our first worries are the people
themselves the families those who are
immediately affected by military
operations and I I think it's it is
important that more consideration
everywhere in the world is taken to
respect those basic rules
in this week you end up speaking with
presidents and prime ministers and
ministers are you worried that the war
in Ukraine is taking up all the
conversation when there are so many
other crises from previous years in
Yemen in Syria in Africa which haven't
been sold which are still there and no
one's talking about indeed there is a
real inequity of attention which is
probably the first big problem and
consequence of the war in Ukraine I have
difficulties except for the parties to
the yemeni the Syrian the sahelian
conflicts to find any interest
whatsoever also from political leaders
to discuss these issues because all the
attention is on Ukraine and then you
have the real-time uh effect of this
conflict the
impact on the world economy the fact
that many of the poorest countries who
have already experienced famine
difficulties to cope with multiple
challenges like climate change and
pandemic are now double and triple
affected by the real-time Ripple effects
of the Ukrainian crisis and so there is
a discrepancy on the one side everybody
looks and finances and tries to do work
in Ukraine and on the other hand there
are an increasing number of Forgotten
conflicts which is worrisome because you
never know when these conflicts will
come back to the international attention
because of Deep Impact that they still
have on societies it's a grim picture
Peter Mauer president of the
international Committee of the Red Cross
thank you for joining us here on Al
Jazeera you're just finishing 10 years
in the job and obviously you look at the
state of the world now compared with 10
years ago there are so many raging
conflicts that were not here a decade
ago Rob James thanks very much our
diplomatic editor James Bay is outside
the UN headquarters there